et pour en débattre nous sommes avec
christian cambon sénateur les
républicains du val de marne vous êtes
également christian cambon président de
la commission des affaires étrangères au
sénat merci d'être avec nous à vos côtés
jérôme lambert député ps vice président
du groupe d'amitié interparlementaire
france azerbaïdjan bonsoir à vous aussi
merci d'être là alors c'est un vin qui a
provoqué la colère du président
azerbaïdjanais ilham aliev qui a peu
goûté évidemment la position des
sénateurs français avant d'en débattre
vous propose d'écouter sa réaction
aujourd'hui des pays situés à des
milliers de kilomètres adopte des lois
leur parlement discute de cette question
qu'est ce que le parlement français à
avoir avec notre question depuis combien
d'années la france est-elle coprésidente
du groupe de minsk at elle fait quelque
chose at-elle pris les mesures concrètes
pour résoudre ce problème
maintenant une fois le problème résolu
vous regardez ce qui se passe le sénat
français adopte une résolution on veut
connaître le haut karabagh si vous les
aimez
alors comme je les dis pendant la guerre
donnez leur ville de marseille changer
son nom keller un deuxième compte à la
barre mais personne ne plus s'immiscer
dans des provocations évidemment de la
part du président azéri mais on entend
surtout beaucoup de colère et en clair
mêlez vous de vos affaires christian
cambon une réaction écoutez je crois
qu'effectivement le sénat est d'abord le
parlement français délibère sur ses
seules initiatives et n'a pas besoin
d'instructions particulières d'un
responsable
étrangers quels qu'ils soient je
comprends très bien que le président
aliyev et n'est pas très bien réagi à
cette initiative mais aussi bien à
l'assemblée nationale qu'au sénat le
pouvoir de voter des résolutions qui ne
sont pas des lois
c'est une manière tout à fait
parlementaire est bien connue d'exprimer
la position des groupes
j'observe que cette résolution a été
adoptée par 305 voix contre une et
encore notre collègue a avoué qu'elle
s'était trompée donc que ses 305 sur 348
vous voyez le consensus +2 je crois que
ces cinq ou six groupes allant de la
droite à la gauche se sont associés ça
veut dire quelque chose ça veut dire
qu'effectivement le parlement et
singulièrement le sénat après une
initiative en réponse aux événements qui
se sont déroulés au karabagh c'est aussi
un signe d'amitié que nous avons adressé
à l'arménie avec lesquels nous avons des
liens anciens l'historique est
privilégiée et c'est aussi un une
manière de dire au gouvernement français
agissez car contrairement à ce que dit
monsieur alif la france et co présidente
du groupe de minsk avec les états unis
et avec la russie vient donc nous avons
des responsabilités et ce qui se passe
dans cette région du caucase nous
concerne tous voilà quand des régions
stratégie géopolitique et donc nous
avions à dire comme nous l'avons redis
encore hier à l'ambassadeur de turquie
que nous avons reçus avec le président
larcher
nous l'avons nous avons dit qu'il y
avait un certain nombre de choses qui ne
nous plaisait pas et c'est le libre
droit du parlement jusqu'à preuve du
contraire dans des pays démocratiques de
s'exprimer comme il l'entend voilà alors
côté arménien le vote du sénat aussi
fait réagir mais évidemment pas du tout
sur le même registre je vous propose
avant de donner la parole à nikol
pashinian d'écouter la réaction du
premier ministre à la arménien j'adresse
ma profonde gratitude à la france et au
peuple français pour la résolution du
sénat sur la reconnaissance de la
république d'artsakh la france qui
affirme son attachement aux valeurs
universelles ainsi qu'au respect des
principes fondamentaux du droit
international alors là on en mer
évidemment réaction beaucoup plus posé
de la part de nikol pashinian vous
comprenez vous ce vote du sénat qui
devient la première instance un taux
même officielle dans le monde à
reconnaître la république autoproclamée
du haut karabagh même l'arménie ne
reconnaît pas cette entité quelle
cohérence je suis vous le dites
vous-même vous n'aviez pas beaucoup de
cohérence dans tout ça d'abord le sénat
ne reconnais pas le sénat demande par un
certain nombre de vins qui met enfin il
faut signaler que les sénateurs absence
elles sont leurs groupes qui votent à
leur place c'est pour ça qu'il ya eu
beaucoup de votants mais ça veut pas
dire que tous les sénateurs étaient
présents et effectivement le sénat a
souhaité que le gouvernement français
reconnaissent la république du haut
karabagh mais c'est pas une
reconnaissance en soit la reconnaissance
on sait pas si elle interviendra mais
vous savez que les résolutions moi je
suis parlementaire depuis fort longtemps
comme mon collègue d'ailleurs prêt de
6,6 et l'inter depuis un moment des
résolutions j'en ai voté quelques unes
je me souviens d'avoir voté une à
quelques années pour inquiéter
d'inspiration lr aussi qu'ils étaient
pour demander la levée des sanctions à
l'encontre de la russie à propos d'eux
des événements dans le nucléaire et vos
crimes et et nous avions voté cette
résolution de l'assemblée nationale il
savait bien malheureusement je l'avais
voter d'ailleurs et vous savez bien que
malheureusement ces sanctions à
l'encontre de la russie existe encore
donc c'est vous dire la portée des
résolutions que nous par notre parlement
le sénat comme l'assemblée nationale
peuvent voter
donc on va bien voir mais en réalité ce
sont des signaux politiques mais ce
n'est pas vrai ce n'est pas une je
dirais
actions qu'ils aient un rapport avec le
droit international ça change rien la
position de la france ni au droit
international et pourtant jérôme lambert
c'est vrai que tout le monde 1 les deux
partis les deux camps on le voit dans
toutes les réflexions tout le monde font
appel au droit international christian
cambon comme si chacun était convaincu
d'avoir le droit international avec lui
dans cette affaire
ok le droit international en
l'occurrence est une chose suffisamment
compliqué je pense que c'est pas
exactement sous cet angle que les choses
se passent d'abord je confirme ce que
vient de dire mon collègue de
l'assemblée jérôme lambert
le sénat a invité le gouvernement c'est
pas le sénat n'a aucun pouvoir pour
connaître un pays que je précise ce
point c'est une résolution c'est
l'expression libre des groupes
politiques qui utilisent ce mode
d'action ce mode d'expression plus
exactement
et donc je pense qu'il faut lui donner
la signification qu'il a la
signification elle et elle est politique
c'est vrai il ya eu une forte émotion au
sénat je pense que c'est aussi à
l'assemblée puisque j'ai l'impression
que à l'assemblée il ya une initiative
qui se prépare à peu près identique en
tous les cas dans des termes à peu près
identiques émanant de la majorité
sénateurs de la majorité à l'assemblée
nationale et qui doit venir en
discussion je crois moi décembre et qui
vise effectivement à s'exprimer sur
cette sur cette situation
le la sphère du haut karabakh est une
affaire très ancienne et on va pas dans
un débat comme ce soir régler ce
problème et si on avait trouvé la
solution il ya belle lurette que ce
serait déjà réglé je rappelle
effectivement que nos diplomates et pas
et parmi les meilleurs du reste depuis
20 ans iej dans ce groupe de minsk et
que jusqu'à présent c'est un fait
aucune solution n'a pu être identifié
justement sur le plan du droit
international et des négociations il y
as peut-être des responsabilités qui
sont tout à fait partagé vous avez dans
ce genre d'affaires c'est pas au tout
noir d'un côté tout blanc de l'eau en
revanche ce qui nous a particulièrement
ému c'est justement des déclarations
telles que le président aliyev en a fait
en dix ans nous avons enfin chassé chez
ses chiens alors quand on signe un
protocole de cessez le feu et que l'on
invite après les populations à revenir
dans dans dans les lieux en question bon
ce sont des termes qui me semble assez
peu favorables à l'établissement de la
paix c'est parce que nous craignons
beaucoup pour la survie physique la
survie physique de debug des populations
arméniennes du haut karabakh
moi je sais j'ai fait projeter devant la
commission des affaires étrangères des
documents que je tiens à la disposition
de nos collègues et qui montre avec
quelle sauvagerie les choses se sont
passées puisque nous avons la certitude
que des militants des miliciens
islamistes se sont se sont participer à
ces opérations et ont utilisé des
procédés qui sont absolument
épouvantable des têtes coupées des
organes coupe et c'est donc la france
encore une fois pour tout un tas de
raisons civilisationnel historique que
sais-je
ce que l'arménie a consenti pour les
libertés en france aussi on pourrait le
rappeler nous avons ce lien là et je
pense que l'expression du sénat qui a
été conduit sous l'autorité du président
du sénat qui avait souhaité que les
groupes puissent exprimer de manière
commune ben je crois que c'est
effectivement et nous revendiquons cette
expression politique en disant s'il y a
des bleus s'il ya des problèmes il ya
d'autres manières de les régler alors
pour l'instant nous n'avons pas et c'est
pas nous qui sommes aux manettes pour
trouver la solution politique
mais dans cette résolution il ya
beaucoup de considérants et nous
demandons justement au gouvernement de
tout faire pour utiliser pour réanimer
en quelque sorte ce groupe de mise
est-ce que vous est ce que vous vous
souvenez tous de même que le
cessez-le-feu a été signé alors que la
france n'a même pas été informés bon bon
il ya des mines il ya des méthodes qui
sont quand même un tout petit peu
compliqué on a eu l'occasion de le dire
à nos collègues russes je pense que le
gouvernement français l'a fait le
président de la république aussi du
reste qui s'entretient tente avec
monsieur pashinian qu'avec monsieur
alief mais le parlement fait ce qu'il
croit devoir faire dans cette affaire il
ya une dimension humanitaire y ait une
dimension cultuelle et culturelle
je suis très heureux que depuis ces
événements ainsi nice y at il été pris
par l'unesco pour sauvegarder un certain
nombre de lieux de culte chrétiens
voilà des sujets qui ont pu animer des
groupes aussi différents que le groupe
communiste le groupe est là
le groupe centriste le groupe socialiste
firent collègues étaient totalement ya
terre et donc voilà je pense qu'on a été
dans notre dans notre droit et pas
toujours en fonction du droit
international car c'est une affaire très
compliquée là la russie effectivement
qui était très intéressé par la
préservation de ces lieux culturels
puisque sa figure de dents dans l'accord
jérôme lambert vous vous offusquez vous
de ne pas avoir été prévenus en tant que
français voilà degré cet accord ron
l'urgence n'était pas plutôt la paix
avant toute chose puisqu'on fait
référence à l'humanitaire justement
c'était à la paix mon collègue à qui
beaucoup de choses j'ai noté j'eus noté
un certain point certains points le
droit international c'est compliqué le
droit international mon cher collègue
président de la commission des affaires
étrangères et de la défense au sénat
certes c'est compliqué mais le droit
international demeure le internationale
le président de la république notre
président de la république a rappelé que
le haut karabagh est est un territoire
azéri il l'a rappelé il ya quelques
jours
donc c'est compliqué non pas tant que ça
il faut simplement respecter le droit
international
quel sera l'avenir du haut karabagh et
bien le haut karabakh est un territoire
azerbaïdjanais
reconnu par les institutions
internationales ont reconnu par la
france comme étant un territoire
azerbaïdjanais
reconnu par la france depuis 1993 un
certain nombre de résolutions des
nations unies sur la la tester des
résolutions qui n'ont jamais été remis
en cause qui avait été voté sous la
présidence de françois mitterrand mais
que jacques chirac n'a pas remis en
cause que nicolas sarkozy n'a pas remis
en cause que françois hollande n'a pas
remis en cause que manuel macro ne remet
pas en cause
donc en fait on cherche aujourd'hui à
faire une histoire de franco française
parce qu'en réalité même l'arménie vous
l'avez rappelé tout à l'heure n'a pas
reconnu l'indépendance du haut-karabakh
et nous en france on est un certain
nombre d'élus qui disent rabat il
faudrait alors on sait le de certaines
images certes c'est la guerre et c'est
vrai que ces images on a tous vu son
émouvante mais vous savez bien
malheureusement on a autant des deux
côtés
c'est à dire on se demande d'ailleurs
si ces images sont vraies si ce sont pas
des images fabriquées compris des vidéos
ou fabriqués savait depuis le temps que
on a vu et des armes de destruction
massives entraîné le monde dans la
guerre parce que il y avait des preuves
de ces armes de destruction massive
alors maintenant quand on me parle me
table ne montre jamais vraiment bien les
choses on me parle de d'éléments de
djihadistes et tout ça deux peut-être
coûté avec des photos à écouter tout ça
il traîne malheureux mais moi j'ai
plutôt tendance à me dire qu'en temps de
guerre
l'information c'est avant tout de la
propagande et la propagande on lui fait
dire ce que l'on veut
les deux côtés un des deux côtés mais là
il se trouve que ça penche du côté de
l'arménie puisqu'en l'occurrence ce sont
avec ses arguments là que certains
s'émeuvent ses mavs en france se met
peut-être ailleurs dans le monde mais je
vois qu'il faut pas parce qu'on était
mue par des images de guerre fabriqués
ou pas fabriquer mais enfin des images
de guerre
il faut pas jeter aux orties le droit
international le droit international dit
clairement que le territoire du haut
karabagh est administrée doit être
administré la totalité à terme par
l'azerbaïdjan
il faudra faire avec et on va essayer on
va essayer le rôle de la france est
d'essayer de faire en sorte que ça se
passe bien
et pour ça il faut pas été exclu du
groupe de mise pourquoi n'en seraient
exclus pourquoi parce que jusqu'à
présent nous avions une position neutre
en quelque sorte on essaye on était
l'ami des azerbaïdjanais est l'ami des
arméniens tout le monde nous
reconnaissait cette qualité les russes
les arméniens les azerbaïdjanais tout le
monde pour ça qu'on avait cette place
justement jeu
pardonnez moi parce qu'il faut donner le
mot de la fin pardonnez-moi jérôme
lambert on a compris en substance l'idée
il faut donner le mot de la fin
christian cambon d'arriver à la fin
justement ceux qui vous disent
aujourd'hui finalement c'est un aveu
d'impuissance et même une faute
politique
il y avait un chercheur directeur
adjoint de l'iris un didier billion qui
disait ça un peu d'impuissance de la
part de notre pays
même faute politique de la part du sénat
qu'est ce que vous répondez ce sera le
mot de la fin
christian cambon mais je conteste tout à
fait l'interprétation de faute politique
encore une fois aussi bien jérôme
lambert a tout à fait raison de dire
qu'il y a bien sûr du droit
international il la reconnaissance du
fait que c'était sûr que le haut
karabakh se situer sur un territoire
azerbaïdjanais
mais manifestement cette solution qui
date de la fin de la guerre 1991 à 1994
ne ne solutionne pas le problème puisque
les incidents ne cessent de se
multiplier
nous savons et je pense que jérôme
lambert le sait donc ce sont des
situations qui date d'une création par
staline on connaît toute cette histoire
et ça ne correspond pas effectivement à
la réalité telle qu'elle est vécue par
les populations et donc on ne tombe pas
dans une dent dans un excès d'émotion
on sait simplement exprimé comme le
parlement a le droit de le faire et
c'est le gouvernement français n'est pas
mêlé à ça il siégeait à son banc et il
fera bien ce qu'il voudra et on il n'est
pas question de le contester et moi je
suis sur la ligne de jérôme lambert à
savoir je souhaite que le gouvernement
prenne des initiatives
on avait l'impression cette épreuve sans
merci en tout cas à tous les deux merci
beaucoup monsieur cambon et lambert
d'avoir accepté de participer à ce débat
sur rt france